Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Questa toilette,
dall’aspetto così futuristico,
ha una seduta riscaldata,
un sistema di autopulizia,
emette una fragranza
a ogni utilizzo, una melodia.
Ha addirittura un getto,
all'interno, tipo bidet:
tutto controllato
da un’app sullo smartphone!
Fantastico, no?
Ci sono addirittura idee
per renderla ancora più utile,
con le prossime versioni:
magari aggiungere un controllo,
un’analisi delle urine, all'interno.
Potrà quindi dirvi
se avete un'infezione in corso,
potrà calcolare
il vostro tasso alcolemico,
magari proporvi la ricetta
di un beverone dopo-sbornia,
sull'iPhone, per la mattina dopo.
Potrà addirittura dirvi se siete incinta,
suonare la cavalcata delle Valchirie,
potrà registrare
gli ormoni della gravidanza.
Addirittura nella versione attuale
dell'app c'è un calendario,
quindi potete registrare
la vostra “regolarità intestinale”.
Mi stupisce che non abbiano messo
una bilancia, all’interno,
così potete sfidare, magari,
gli amici su Facebook, a ogni utilizzo!
Io non so quanti di voi correranno subito
a comprare questa toilette:
di sicuro tutte le donne in sala
che convivono con un uomo,
perché c’è anche
una funzione utilissima:
quando ci si allontana,
abbassa automaticamente la tavoletta.
Benvenuti nell’Internet of Things,
che riesce anche a metter fine
anche alle eterne liti coniugali.
Ma cos'è questo Internet of Things,
Internet delle Cose?
L'Internet delle Cose
è la connettività di ogni oggetto,
in ogni momento e in ogni luogo.
50 miliardi di dispositivi
saranno connessi ad Internet
entro i prossimi 5 anni.
Ma dove sono tutti questi dispositivi?
Nelle nostre case, magari
intorno a noi, o addosso a noi,
addirittura magari dentro di noi.
Ci sono dei sensori che misurano i livelli
di pressione e di ossigeno
all'interno del corpo.
Questi vengono ingeriti e poi
vengono assorbiti dall’organismo,
quindi comunicano i dati all'esterno
con i medici, i dati diagnostici.
Ci sono addirittura defibrillatori
che comunicano i dati
con i medici all'esterno.
Oppure pensate
ai sistemi che controllano
le infrastrutture critiche
di intere nazioni:
centrali elettriche,
cartelli stradali intelligenti
connessi tra loro,
semafori intelligenti.
Oppure anche nelle automobili:
le case automobilistiche
sono sempre più attente a queste cose.
Inseriscono la connettività all’interno
di tutte le automobili, ormai:
ci sono sistemi
di diagnostica dei pneumatici,
del tachimetro, controlli della velocità,
controlli dello sterzo,
controlli dei freni,
ci sono addirittura case che aggiornano
la centralina a distanza, via Internet.
Magari la casa madre
in Germania sta aggiornando
le auto vendute negli Stati Uniti,
di notte, mentre sono in garage.
Ci sono poi applicazioni sul telefono
che vi fanno vedere
come state guidando,
i vostri consumi,
il vostro stile di guida.
Oppure proviamo ad avvicinarci
a qualcosa che è nelle vostre case:
ad esempio, quanti di voi
hanno una Smart TV,
una televisione che permette
di vedere un video su Internet,
o ascoltare una canzone su Youtube?
Oppure una netcam?
Sono sempre più diffuse le netcam,
vi permettono di vedere
sul cellulare cosa avviene
nella stanza del vostro bambino
al piano di sopra,
oppure guardare cosa fa il vostro cane
mentre siete in ufficio.
Vederlo mentre mangia
il divano, scodinzolando,
e noi siamo in ufficio, impotenti.
Non pensate che questi oggetti
siano così lontani dalla realtà,
perché alla fine quando voi
cambierete la televisione, o la lavatrice,
è facile che questa
sia connessa a Internet,
perché ormai tutti i nuovi dispositivi
hanno questo tipo di funzioni.
Sempre in alcune case
ci sono, per esempio,
termostati intelligenti,
connessi ad Internet.
Questi termostati sanno,
tramite il cellulare,
dove ci troviamo, se stiamo
andando verso l'ufficio
o se stiamo tornando a casa,
in quale stanza siamo,
cambiano la temperatura
delle stanze di conseguenza.
Oppure le bilance
che mandano i dati di fitness
sui nostri profili online.
Ci sono addirittura dei giovani italiani
che hanno inventato
il materasso intelligente,
un coprimaterasso, in realtà,
che impara come dormiamo,
le nostre abitudini,
sa quando deve scaldare,
quale parte di letto,
e a che ora, addirittura.
Questi dispositivi misurano
anche come dormiamo,
ci possono anche dire
se stiamo russando...
- Hai russato questa notte! -Non è vero!
- Lo dice il materasso! - Ah, ok.
Il pericolo è che ci dica anche
con chi abbiamo dormito -
vedo tante facce preoccupate,
qua davanti...
Alla fine, però,
non vi ho ancora detto chi sono io.
Mi chiamo Stefano,
e sono almeno 10 giorni
che non compro un nuovo
dispositivo elettronico di questo tipo.
Sono dipendente dalla tecnologia,
tendo a riempirmi di questi oggetti.
Però nel mio lavoro mi occupo di sicurezza
e di insicurezza, cioè di hacking.
Tendo a circondarmi
di questi oggetti, come dicevo,
ma la mia paranoica deformazione
professionale mi porta a chiedere:
ma se tutti questi oggetti non fossero
veramente così sicuri
come vorremmo credere?
Quale sarebbe, probabilmente,
la vostra risposta a questa domanda?
"Beh, non è un mio problema!
L'importante è che la TV
riesca a collegarsi a Internet,
e a mostrare Peppa Pig a mio figlio
e tenerlo buono
mentre lo scarico da YouTube"
Beh, in realtà questa domanda
se la sono posta tanti ricercatori,
tanti esperti di sicurezza informatica,
la comunità hacking underground.
Sono tutti molto attenti a questo settore,
perché è un campo
con il quale è bello misurarsi.
In più l'hacking di questi oggetti
finisce sulle prime pagine dei quotidiani,
perché sono oggetti
che tanti di noi hanno in casa.
Pensate che gli ultimi
attacchi informatici
sono partiti da reti di frigoriferi,
lavatrici, televisori, termostati.
Reti di attacchi informatici,
tutti con il benestare inconsapevole
dei loro proprietari,
che magari non hanno neanche cambiato
la password predefinita
dell’elettrodomestico.
Pensate, magari - voi siete qua
ad ascoltare TED, da casa
la vostra lavatrice sta attaccando
il sito del New York Times.
“Beh, in realtà questo ancora
non è un mio problema.”
Magari interessa le aziende,
ma ancora non mi tocca direttamente.
Allora prendiamo oggetti di uso
quotidiano, che sono nelle nostre case,
ad esempio, questi oggetti hanno
le nostre informazioni personali:
il termostato conosce,
come dicevo, in che stanza siamo,
magari dove siamo, col cellulare:
la bilancia conosce quanto pesiamo
e conosce anche quanti bicchieri d'acqua
abbiamo bevuto, magari;
o lo smartphone conosce
il percorso abituale
della nostra corsetta di fitness serale,
sa esattamente che percorso facciamo;
oppure le netcam e le televisioni
sono una vetrina
di quel che avviene in salotto,
o nella stanza di sopra.
Quindi questi dati sono molto importanti,
e se vanno a finire nelle mani sbagliate
potrebbe diventare pericoloso.
Beh, questo inizia un po' a far vacillare
la nostra risposta iniziale.
Be', se vi dicessi che è possibile
modificare cartelli
come questo, a distanza?
O semafori intelligenti?
Oppure pensate a una notizia
di un paio di mesi fa,
dove BMW e Mini hanno dovuto aggiornare,
sempre via Internet, remotamente,
le loro automobili
perché tramite un'app sullo smartphone
era possibile aprire
le portiere, per esempio.
Ci sono addirittura ricercatori
delle Università di Washington e San Diego
che sono riusciti a controllare
a distanza delle automobili
coi sistemi di controllo delle automobili:
quindi mostrare una velocità
diversa sul tachimetro,
oppure gestire i freni
delle automobili, o le luci,
con un rischio conseguente
per chi si mette alla guida.
Con questo, il "non è un mio problema"
iniziale non regge più tanto.
Allora, vi ricordate il cardiostimolatore
di cui vi ho parlato all’inizio?
Ci sono altri ricercatori
che sono riusciti
a collegarsi a questo cardiostimolatore:
quindi, a distanza, cambiare i parametri,
e addirittura indurre la defibrillazione.
Non in un paziente vero, per fortuna:
era una prova.
Di fronte a questo, il “non è
un mio problema” non regge proprio più.
Tornando alla nostra immagine iniziale,
quella della toilette,
il sistema di controllo e di sicurezza
del bluetooth di questa toilette
è impostato come 0000.
Capite che è molto facile
collegarsi a queste toilette
e fare degli scherzi
a chi le sta utilizzando.
Magari facciamo aprire il getto del bidet,
facciamo partire l'aria calda,
apriamo e chiudiamo il coperchio!
L’hacking può essere
molto divertente, in alcuni casi...
Ma a questo punto, dopo che avete visto
tutte queste cose,
se io vi chiedessi
la stessa domanda iniziale:
“Se tutti questi oggetti
non fossero veramente
così sicuri come vorremmo credere?”
come sarebbe diventata, ora,
la vostra risposta?
Io spero che adesso la risposta sia:
“Si, è un mio problema.
Devo fare qualcosa.”
È giusto che ci circondiamo
quotidianamente
di oggetti di questo tipo,
di nuove tecnologie,
senza però perdere di vista
i nuovi rischi ai quali ci esponiamo
e la centralità che abbiamo noi
nel proteggerci da questi rischi,
prima e dopo l'acquisto,
nella scelta del prodotto
e nell'utilizzo del prodotto.
Quindi cosa possiamo fare noi,
concretamente, da parte nostra,
per proteggerci da queste cose?
In primo luogo,
quanti di voi leggono i manuali?
Nessuno legge più i manuali,
ormai i prodotti sono intuitivi
e facili da usare,
siamo presi dall'entusiasmo
del nuovo acquisto
e non vogliamo leggere il manuale.
Eppure leggendo il manuale
capiamo esattamente
quali sono le funzioni di quel prodotto.
Perché dobbiamo sapere che cosa offre,
in primo luogo per capire che cosa fa,
ma in secondo luogo per spegnere
tutto ciò che non ci serve.
È inutile lasciare porte aperte
da cui gli hacker possono intrufolarsi.
Per esempio, è inutile tenere acceso
il comando vocale
della vostra televisione in salotto,
che di fatto attiva un microfono
nel vostro salotto,
se sapete già che userete
sempre il telecomando.
È importante poi dare solo
le informazioni private
necessarie a questi prodotti.
Perché possono sempre
essere attaccati e visti da qualcuno.
Per esempio, un termostato
che deve collegarsi al meteo,
per cambiare la temperatura di casa,
non deve sapere per forza la vostra via
o il numero civico dell'abitazione.
È sufficiente che sappia
la città, o il CAP.
E poi è importante anche
tenere aggiornati questi prodotti,
perché se vengono solo installati
e mai più toccati,
le vecchie versioni sono soggette
a errori di programmazione,
sono soggette ad attacchi
che gli hacker possono utilizzare.
Quindi vanno tenuti
costantemente aggiornati.
E infine, un'accortezza
tanto facile quanto importante:
cambiare la password
ai propri dispositivi,
o almeno inserirne una
laddove prima non c'era,
come un cellulare per esempio.
Magari utilizziamo una password complessa:
non utilizziamo “123456”,
che tra l'altro ha già vinto
il premio, nel 2014,
come password più utilizzata.
Adesso la sanno tutti, tra l'altro.
Quindi quello
che vorrei ottenere io, oggi,
è che voi di fronte al prossimo
nuovo acquisto tecnologico,
vi chiediate: “come faccio a fargli fare
tutto quello che voglio”
e subito dopo, “come faccio a non fargli
fare tutto quello che non voglio?"
Grazie!
(Applausi)